the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
you
right
my name is Bose Leonard Milan Carter
sempron and rosser's not here right now
and our team leaders camp and we're
working on Oh J sealer for community in
Nicaragua we were partnered with the NGO
Assam Phoenix which is a organization
that does rural sustainable development
projects with multiple communities in
Nicaragua and they do projects such that
promote clean water electricity income
generation also educational projects
that help the community be healthy so
our project centers around the community
el roble are that we visited while we
were down there and they have a large
orange harvest crop that they get and
there's no market for the oranges during
the harvest season because everybody's
harvesting oranges so the idea is to
create a way for them to sell the
oranges or product from the oranges in
the offseason to generate income and
they were introduced a pasteurization
process to preserve the orange juice by
Auto Phoenix in through a the University
in Managua so that that process is in
place and we are trying to develop a way
for them to seal a plastic bag in order
to preserve the juice and this is
actually stemming off of a project that
was started during last year's d-lab
energy class and you see that project
picture at the bottom here and are our
specifications that we want to achieve
with our project is to have it the
device be able to run off 120 volts of
AC current and
while in the seal should be done while
removing the air from the bag so there's
no air in the bag to prevent spoiling of
the juice after its sealed before it's
sold and we also want to create and
maintaining the durable user-friendly
interface that was in game last year's
with last year's project so this is a
bigger picture of last year's project
and it sealed bags nicely and all but
there's several areas that we feel need
improving on before it can actually
really be used the first one is the
power supply between last year and this
year the community we're working in got
rid of all their 12-volt batteries like
that because they got a micro hydro grid
and so now they're running on 120 AC so
we need to think it'd actually be able
to run on the power that they have I
mentioned removing all the air from the
bags the preservation process isn't very
strong so it's a key part of making sure
the orange juice stays good the wide
flat surface that their ceiling on here
makes it very very difficult to do that
so we want to improve that as well and
then we talked about
comfort inn using it the light but
indicated whether something is hot or
not was right about here and he would
use it from the other side it's very
difficult to see there's a latch that's
really difficult to open and trying to
get the bags to get all the air out
because of the wide flat surface was
also very difficult and the control the
timing circuit there that they they've
been out of the box timing circuit
mainly I think because of limited time
that cost twenty six dollars so we're
also designing a simplified timing
circuit built out of just components
that is only going to be a couple of
hours
so we wanted to first go into
experimentation and see what needed to
be done to yes get a good seal on a bag
um so we first started off with what
type of plastic do we need we basically
tested we got some plastic from
Nicaragua and we brought it back and
turned out to be 25 thousandth of an
inch so we're testing with 25 thousands
of an inch and 45,000 7-inch that
because there's various plastics there
and so we wanted test with multiple
types of plastic to accommodate that in
addition to that we wanted to see what
temperature was needed to fully seal
plastic so we use the standard impulse
are the industry standard which is the
impulse sealer to seal a bag and we used
a thermocouple to determine the
temperature we got a temperature of
about 195 Celsius and you can see gets a
good seal like this let me pass it
around if you want the water should be
orange juice but uh well yeah so we got
a 195 Celsius that's the temperature we
need two hits and in addition of the
temperature another factor is pressure
how much force do you need to put down
on a nichrome wire to get a good seal so
we use the force plate sensor and push
down on it we got about 56 newtons which
translates to about 169 kilopascals on
the neck room wire and you can see over
here with if you don't apply enough
pressure you get a sure like a
perforated line where the seals like was
a lot of gaps in between the seals so
this is not a good seal because there
wasn't enough pressure although the time
was perfect Oh with this with a six
kilogram weight you got a good solid
seal on the on the bag everything looks
good waters not leak and
that is ideal in terms of timing we also
want to make sure you apply the right
amount of time or else it melts the
possible melts so what we did was we had
a standard weights we applied it to our
rig and tested to tell with its constant
voltage different timing sort of we ran
ran the device for a certain amount of
time and then increases slowly cincy has
increased more time this was enough this
wasn't enough pressure because the TC
the dimples but you can see over time
that is a very small seal 21 us melted
and so with various weights and various
voltages and varying the time we got our
figured out exactly what we need so in
terms of power voltage oh that's not too
Briana so before I get into a different
test of power voltage if I notice that
it says like 5 volts 10 books 12 we were
talking about 120 volts ac this is
because we decided that the best way to
run something off the wall power is
actually just to buy an adapter and plug
it in and convert it to 12 volts DC
running something off the wall makes it
very difficult to have our timing
circuit work and probably have to
rectify that into DC anyway 120 volts
with our nichrome that's like a 4 ohm
resistor would have to add either more
resistors that would do nothing for the
heating and be expensive because they
have to be big power resistors or lots
more nichrome wire which would again be
expensive we built our own adapter the
price came out to just about the same as
with 12 volt 34 m adapters are selling
for
and it would be more complicated and
harder to replace so it turns out the
best solution to running it up the wall
is just to buy an adapter running off
the 12 volts at anyways so we did tests
with power and voltage or power
controlled by what voltage we were
putting across a resistor and the time
that we left it on for these are just a
couple samples there to see it five
volts even when we were doing it for a
minute we didn't get hot enough to melt
the back at all I know the pictures
aren't really great but they're what
festival at 10 volts we had a good seal
in just 20 seconds and at 12 volts by
the time it was 14 seconds we were
already sealing it too much so this was
giving this a good idea of our
trade-offs between how much power we're
using what range of powers and times we
can choose I think we did get a good
seal of the 12 volt set about like eight
or ten seconds but didn't really have
at all physical picture of that to show
you so that was leaked experimentation
that we did and we wanted to use this
results in to our design so when we
design our products we wanted to take
two things in the mind functionality and
usability thinking about functionality
is we want the users to be looking down
the products so they can use it on a
table and they also want a nice latch
system so as you can see over here we
have an angled products oh and since
angled you can look down on it use it
easily should be taller but yeah and
with this angled play you can have a bag
pain down as such so that the liquid
will be in the bag and that you can get
a good an airtight seal here oh and then
another bonus is at the excess juice
that you we're sealing fruit juice in
order to get an airtight seal the extra
juice you can just let run off after you
make this deal you can have a clot
sitting right here to catch it
says another and the sprit their springs
in this arm that allow you once you have
one to be able latch system they'll keep
the same force for every seal so you'll
know that you have enough force and that
given the timing circuit it will run for
the same amount of time so the seals
will be the same and then wore on the
latch system the springs also provide
some give that will allow this to be
compressed a little bit more than the
necessary force for a seal so we can
just have a simple rotating hang out of
sheet metal something that's rally a
little Nicaragua
then you can slide it over like the
picture and then when you want it off
you can press down slightly better golf
are you ready to go
so here's some future things that we
need to work on one thing would be
combining the ergonomics the usability
of this product in addition to the
functionality we were doing a sample
test on a basically just two pieces of
wood testing uh putting weight on top
and so we need to add an a chrome wire
onto the base of this actually seal bags
with this design in addition that we
need to finalize the circuitry and just
a design housing device for the
electronics that we would be placing on
the side in addition to that once we
have this is completed basically just
get users to test it to make sure it's
you palm intuitive easy-to-use and a
great product overall we'd like to think
I can Amy Amit's d-lab overall and our
community partner also Phoenix are there
any questions
so
you're seamless your juice right now are
you testing that by sailing through
water gets into silver bowl
via via test
it's probably time to buy some lunches
and yeah I would buy the like the super
extra filthy version throw some light
sticks and rocks into it and at one
point it would be worth it to test like
actually squeeze your own juice it's not
that hard to make a bit
out working the lunch
and whitening this whole name
we wanted to be able to I guess be
easily under used by one person ideally
so if that having you want we're not
sure that this like there could be cases
if you're filling like leader bags or
two later bags of juice if they're
selling it to restaurants for kind of
like wholesale like two restaurants this
force pressing down might not be enough
to pull the bag so they might need to be
holding back pressing a button so you
want want to be able to do one thing at
time with your freaking in addition to
that you also want to have a concept
force for each seal so there can be
variable forces if you like push harder
less than each time worth green I'm
going to say that it's also might be
easy for these guys to remember like how
much force then always put enough course
on it but when I and I was doing some
tests I wasn't always getting enough for
some there and the people who are doing
this are women and girls so it's like
even like 9 10 12 year old girls being
able to lash it down from having to hold
it's a bit of a classroom this is a new
arm we left the last year's model in
nicaragua with house of Phoenix and it
works off the 12 volt battery I'm not
sure if it's being used
in another community we delivered it
last yes not orange juice season at the
moment so exactly right now it's not
being used I don't know whether they
will take it out to the community did
you last year's project also did not
have the specification to remove the air
so using that while removing here is
also more typical to feedback that you
have as based on this
others field from our spring break trip
down to Nicaragua and that finding their
with in El Roble was looking flip house
would ya
show pictures of that testing yeah we we
have pictures
no no thank you
one of the funds
that you're trying to create sort of at
least notionally sterile stuff oh you
might want to start it might be time to
start thinking about segregating this
thing into the stuff you have to keep
clean and the stuff you don't have to
clean
is like having to reach over with your
you know your sterile hand that's in all
the juice and all the stuff you're
trying to reclaim and like reach over
hit the button on the top of the timer
is going to become a drag that like that
button somehow has to stay clean if you
can give them things like foot pedals
and elbow switches and you know sucks of
it
just to think about the process and like
how you're going to keep the clean stuff
clean and not and sort of minimize the
amount of stuff actually I think you
sterile
um there aren't devices that use low
power like this I'm not sure what the
price per to the impulse sealer is but
running it off batteries are the right
Hydra grid you can't use that it uses
more power than there's a limit to the
amount of power that any like device
they've run off the micro hydro grid
that ass of Phoenix is installed there's
a lot to draw so also Phoenix doesn't
allow use of irons or like hair dryers
or hair straighteners or anything that's
heavy power intensive like that um when
we compare what we have to the design
that was made last year I think we're
probably about ten dollars less which
not if you not include a battery I think
that makes us around forty dollars
instead of around fifty dollars
which
no it instead of sealing our slide about
the commercial ones so use a large
amount of power for about half a second
this will use like 30 watts for more
like 10 seconds these are our photos
working in the field in a house we
stayed a novel are a group of about 8 10
8 to 10 of the women of the town came
and we gave a demonstration of how it
works roll through so this is we found
out that there were notable batteries so
we strung up a bunch of double-a and
triple-a batteries just to be able to do
the demonstration so we got like
somewhere between like six and ten bags
that put the batteries
so this is the process
and they they actually got the seal a
few bags themselves let me know if you
have any questions as we're going
through
we heard from the community partners
that they didn't want to hear so in
terms of leg room for error word we're
not sure it does i wonder if there's a
correlation between like the size of
that bar thats hanging
presumably if you make a really sharp
edge so ideally we're going to have the
nichrome wire close as close to the edge
as possible together as clean a seal as
possible because the more the further it
the further end it is the more overlap
thirds so it's going to be potentially
boyer this easier to get us to like
clamp it like this work versus talk
about
and I took you the less well enough yeah
try to run enough solar as well but this
is getting away from the presentation
anymore so how many bags if you guys
over the question is master Oh including
the testing where we were just going
down
five gallons worth of orange juice or my
gala for the water and
we usually just she went off every now
we've been stealing bags the size of at
least 20 yourself but that was with our
kind of works like models that we
haven't combined this sealer with this
ergonomic application of it yet to have
something that about those bags the
individual bags wasn't available
or get along too they get in a lot too
and we have about six feet of that tube
here
how about
yeah you'll see you'll see I'm magica yo
we have the long tube and that's for
like the individual size we aren't sure
that that would always be with it
especially if they're like one or two
liter bags so we wanted something I
think we're trying to go a little more
flexible rather than specifically from
would only be a advantage with the long
tube
more
something
we're all you have built what you
ceiling is like another half of bags
with an orange juice or so you don't
have to hold like a philly one-liter
bags you don't have to open 50 pounds
bags above this thing but if you if you
have it sort of doesn't continuous
processing only got like a half a bags
with the stuff supported above the
amount of what size the bag is and then
you keep filling it what you made that
last seal then it makes the support
problems
start thinking
does the once the orange juice is sealed
doesn't need refrigeration
as long as there's other pastures
is that a standard for
besides a bubble in your new room that
can remain or does it have to be
absolutely
oh that's Steve us we're not sure
any progress there
I think I think most answers we got to
say yes there needs to be removed there
needs to be nowhere and whether that's a
like overstating the requirement or
actually they're really actually nice
Camino air that's where we're unsure i
think so we're making our goal be there
and actually know where you see if you
can actually successfully seal with zero
air 40 noticeable air I think they did
one with our flat one but what
that we have no air in yeah how crazy is
there pasteurization poses
hahaha under the pot boil for 10 minutes
in the foot of the bag so so much
surgery couch hasn't yeah so
I bet it depends a lot more on even
the non-public years in Tibet
because there's air in a bottle sent
away there's air at the top of you don't
like there's air at the top of the bag
but the junk pickles that you know it's
pasteurized and it's highly acid
what's left
yeah well it'd be it'd be good to both
be able to answer that and also know
like even if you have the answer that
air is ok if they are convinced that air
is not okay that may be a knockout blow
and so practicing to make sure the
ergonomics and whatever your process are
set up such that you can actually ensure
that most of the time you're getting a
bag with no air visible I think would be
good to practice that a bunch
are you guys talking about
I'm just wondering
it probably wouldn't be directly look
like that this was an earlier model
we've got it covered in plastic probably
when the way we're going to go last
year's was painted or lacquered group so
definitely be some kind of wipe down
and the long is it
when kills wood is going wet dry wet dry
wet dry wet dry over and over
but if you're going to run it all day
long wet
you just might want to make it out of
something
it's nice to be able to make the
services flattened so you can clean them
so it really soft final dick
and hardware stuff but harder what
think one of my interns also was
capturing the remote you
yeah and that case what a very sterile
surface and where as soon as you can get
do you have an extra eight inches of
your roll of plastic or six inches of
your old plastic
wrap that bottom portion
that was like kind of run off Sheamus
you don't actually have to worry about
cleaning your wood is
it's also best friend Emily over phone
early soak into the device rather than
being reclaim
only the first little tables
okay thanks you guys
hi we're the charcoal group i'm viviane
i'm jessica and i'm kurt and our project
mentors are Amelia raise your hand and
Steve over there okay um so first oh
alright alright man Matt it sorry our
main motivation for our project stems
from the work we did with a Nicaraguan
based NGO called group of Phoenix and
more specifically we worked with a
cooperative called the Maharis Alana's
which is the solar women basically we
introduced the idea of d labs agri waste
charcoal and for those of you aren't
familiar with it it's basically a
process of making charcoal out of agri
waste or biomass instead of wood so you
know you reduce deforestation and it
burns a lot cleaner we really wanted to
improve this process so that the women
would feel more comfortable integrating
this into their everyday lives or
possibly using this as a business
activity for them right now there is a
general discomfort with a process and
just can talk to you a little bit more
about those specifics so what was really
unique to wear a group was that we had
the language um to get the direct
feedback from the women so we didn't
have to go through a third person said
you know I was able to interpret exactly
what they were saying and you had I see
I've highlighted here that the biggest
issue for them today is still covering
the barrel because they cannot bathe
afterwards after dealing with so much
heat of the barrel they say that the
heat is too intensive for them and then
they you know would bathe with cold
water and then they would get sick
afterwards so that's the biggest gap for
them right now even when we um discuss
the different project ideas that we had
to make the charcoal process better they
still brought us back to we really want
you to work on the
beryl do something so that it doesn't
feel so hot
so we're going to show you a video of
how a man doing a charcoal gray one
account password but this is a third
charcoal burn that the women are doing
by themselves we train them and then we
had them do the first two by themselves
they were successful this is the third
one and you can see that even in the
third trial there's still some
coordination in the barrel ceiling this
is a current design where the barrel
sits on top of the bricks and you have
to tilt and kick and sometimes kick too
much and so what we can see here are the
main point the main pain points of the
process which are not that right now
which are the heat intensity of the
process which is what they've identified
and of course the safety issue and we
realize that we need to address these
two concerns while still meeting the
same quality of a char Goulburn great so
in order to meet these criteria that
jess just highlighted our design
submerges the bricks on which the barrel
sit into the ground and so basically
what we've done here I can show you on
our model here this is a one of the
ideas of the charcoal bird is that it's
it uses commonly available materials
like a oil drum so I've used a natty ice
can hear two in the same spirit and the
so instead of sitting on top of the
ground it now sits on bricks that are
submerged into holes and so the design
is pretty simple there is a dugout hole
there are six bricks that line three
channels which allow for air flow in
this space right here the the ground and
the barrel form a seal so the the barrel
does not move once it's been lit on fire
and we've calculated the air flow so
that there is sufficient air flow
through those channels into the holes
that are at the bottom of the barrel so
that the so that the while it's burning
there's enough air and so to work on
sealing these channels we have we've
come up with these metal plates right
here so essentially this is just a sheet
metal and has these handles on top we
call them and they can be pushed in
underneath the over rather the three
channels to seal them and just with a
little bit of sand it forms a seal
around the whole barrel so it eliminates
the need for tilting the barrel kicking
it kicking out the bricks and all that
and we experimented with a number of
shapes here at the top so this is a
semi-circular we also have triangular
shapes and then different various types
of handles which Jessica will go into in
a second so an overview of the benefits
of this design compared to the existing
the existing portion of the process that
we're trying to fit our first that it
minimizes the heat exposure because the
flaming barrel is now in the ground and
there's no space for the there's
minimised space for this heat to come
out the second is that one person can
seal the the barrel rather than needing
to and we can show video of that right
now
yeah so this is the entire process we've
all talked through this third is that we
can even still light the barrel through
the channels and the barrel doesn't move
once it's on fire and flaming so as you
can see all jessica is doing here is
just pushing the the plates in at a safe
distance and with minimal exposure to
heat basically
um and so from our experiment we were
able to conclude what designs of sheet
and handles were better equipped to meet
our project attributes we wanted to be
able to steer the sheet and the better
design for that was the semi circular
plate in terms of maneuvering and being
precise about where the sheet was going
the lipped handle which is this one
right here allowed for the wood to come
in and kind of fit right there I'm just
enough to be able to maneuver the sheet
into where we wanted it the lifting
potential of the lift handle allowed us
to sort of kick the sheet up a little
bit if it ever got stuck right before
the break um and the three sheets worked
equally as well um to diminish the heat
exposure and to lessen the time that it
took to seal the barrel now stepping
back for a second the sheet metal is
only one of three up sealing barrel
ceiling alternatives that we're
considering right now the other two are
inserting a break into the channel of
the dugout and covering the rest with
sand and the third is even simpler than
that just shoveling in or pouring in
sand into the three holes um and of
course on the Left we have different
sort of design specific excuse me
specifications that we want this to me
because it's part of the process that
before was most heat insensitive um
you'll see there's an even spread right
now of all the three designs for example
the sheet metal is best in diminishing
or lessening the time that it takes to
seal but the sand could be done from
farthest away you just sort of take the
stand and throw it into the barrel throw
it in on the side but this is due to the
metrics of the attributes right for
example the labor intensity we consider
that it's easier to seal the hole but
you do have to spend some time finding
the sheet metal which is readily
available in Nicaragua but you still
have to make a manufacture the sheet um
sheet metal with the handles only ones
though so in our experiment we concluded
that our dugout was successful in
addressing the need to reduce heat
exposure it channels all the heat down
into the dugout instead of at the people
working on it we also were able to
decrease a safety risk of the tipping
kick method our sheet metal seals were
also successful in creating a seal and
resulting in a quality burn we did get
some really good carbonized material out
of this burn but there are definitely
still improvements to be made we can
still work on the maneuverability and
handling of these seals with the handles
and we can also work on adding a little
more distance between the person and the
barrel and so we're at our next steps
which are going to be to send the
documented process of our new barrel
design or charcoal making design to the
women and they're going to make a
charcoal burn early next week we're
going to phone call them and talk to
them directly off of them directly and
get their feedback on what the heat
experience was and see how they how they
can accept any explain that and whether
it's better worse um and finally we're
going to continue to look at improving
the sheet metal design and seeing how we
can manufacture it easier or how we can
just get it a better design solution
money maneuver it better and finally of
course we're here to incorporate your
input so questions
questions yes Benjamin have you been
able to talk to them about the three
different options of how to seal
in terms of like would you rather make a
play where we'd rather
so no the answer is no I'm not about
those three specific designs but um in
our conversations with Lindsay which is
sort of their project coordinator or
early ace on our liaison with the
community um she says that she continues
to say that the the heat of it is the
biggest exposure so rather than have
them to the test trials and all the
experimentation of like which feels best
or taking all this data that we've been
taking we try to get the data first and
then submit our conclusive you know
recommendation to them and then that's
what they're going to do this week
to describe all of it
yeah right now when you train a
community to make a charcoal burn
there's a nifty document with diagrams
that D lab has produced that tells them
you know how to make the holes or how to
set up the bricks and all the process
and so we're going to do that they've
already been trained with that and they
have that document we train them over
spring break and so we're just going to
sort of an addendum in appendix to what
the new process should be and how they
should dig the hole and all that so they
can do their charcoal bird next week and
we have all those specifications for the
whole based on like air flow right so
how are you sighs I mean exactly so we
can send them very very exact so there's
probably before with your little dog
no we were there to train a personally
you can yeah it's hard to communicate
just with a document of step-by-step
instructions even though they're really
well drafted because they still have
questions on it's really about
understanding the why of things but now
that they understand the why of things
like why has to be sealed at a certain
time now it's a matter of just saying
instead of mounting the barrel on the
bricks instead make a hole and serve
bricks and put the barrel on top yeah
seems like how do you if you're gonna
plug the hole with up with a third brick
how do you get the brook there
well I mean that's that does that
inevitably involve your hand that happen
enjoy way from the mouth sure so that
you can make other contraptions that
we've considered like a reach sort of
like the things that you use to reach
really far away and just grab it and put
it there but um the simplest design is
that you know when I'll show you the
picture when you can walk right next to
the barrel you can sort of stand right
here and you're not feeling any heat so
you can if you just drop in the brick
you're technically not feeling any heat
over you whereas even with the sheet
metal design you're directly in front of
the channel that does have the heat
coming out of it if that makes any sense
comparatively I think a lot of it is
smoke to that justice has a lot of smoke
comes out of shape and comparatively
remember that it was all on bricks
before so all the heat was radiating out
of the bottom and that was going threat
to their feet to their ankles and 19 if
there's no it's just as easy for them to
bring nine bricks at six boroughs then
you know the easiest way to tell them
how wide the whole reasons that it
should be a required just measure it
with the bricks you're about to use the
plugin
but can't get there to put the brick
mol efficiencies
right so that's why for the time being
so just you tested with the hot barrel
putting the bricks in not what the hell
no we've time tested okay because I I
question that you wouldn't expose to
heat but putting a break-in in our video
on I was significantly closer at the
sheet metal and and I had to be over the
over the channel so i can only imagine
the mean on the side of it with the
smoke isn't rising would be better but
that is actually what we're going to be
testing on monday which is we're gonna
have to we're going to do two barrels
and we're going to be testing the
thermometer readings like along the
different points around the barrel at
different distances are you converging
on what we testing where its hottest so
if there is a really significant
difference between right above the right
above the channel and here that we know
that this is like a safer area or a
better area for them to
there's a high-resolution thermometer
they were borrowing from 2671 and lardo
and that's one of the leaping infrared
thermometers no no it's just like I mean
temperature
surface no not on Skinner surface just
like you can just hold it so air
temperature I got your messages I'm not
sure I haven't looked at it but that's
the description says there's a surface
one that depends on mica surface the
surface roughness and the surface like
change of temperature to write and
material but this one is just supposed
to be able to help you have something to
mentality newest course the most likely
radiating to it you're not gonna measure
anything after that nettles but absorb
you see is smoke coming out of it
it's so smokes coming out of the
channels at the bottom right is that
happening the entire time are only after
you see all the time on my athletes
they're everything you can to the bottom
the top is just more of a like there's
actually fire coming out of it and the
wind changes direction really quickly
that if you're standing close to brown
it could actually be pretty close to the
flames of the way the way it's the way
the barrel is sealed now is with the top
first and then kicking out the brakes
afterwards so we've just stuck with that
this thing going wiggling back before
when the top is over because maybe some
members
but if you're not wiggling a barrel
maybe you just seal the bottom of first
and smoke
bottom and many conceal the club
I think cuz like smoke is still coming
out at like kind of like I level when
the top is open so our intuition tells
us to see on the top first before we
turn or maybe that's another experiment
yeah yeah Gavin point about you know
measuring heat is complicated and so
it's coming at you in two different ways
and your measurement devices Michael to
measure one other of those ways you
might want to try a bunch of different
ways I mean it's because what you're
going to be getting is radiant heat as
focus as this sound you might actually
get a more useful measurement by like
you know taking notes we do yeah either
how hot does it deal or like you know if
you want to get some kind of integrated
measurement you know you buy like you
know three cantaloupes because those at
least look like human beings and will
measure how to get 15 minutes later you
gotta do you know something but you need
an absorber that looks like a person
skin because like you know
the metal is going to reflect all the
radio [ __ ] so we serve a couple of see
another way to do that is to just wrap
half or thurs the barrel vertically in
tin foil and use some sort of
metallic wire to stretch it boiled
one-third barrel or half the barrel and
that will
act as a huge relationship so if you
want to that would just tell you here if
the heat is coming from hot air coming
out
radiation off the barrel
and then you would know actually what
your problem is
check so
any other comments especially on the
sheet metal seal and what not I just
wouldn't bank on the women being able to
do a test or next week as part of your
critical path sure Lindsay did already
say that they wanted to do a burn that's
why we are not counting on it but yeah
but yeah absolutely but I think you
should try to make that happen but also
if it takes them a week to make it
happen right be able to work with that
to you sliding the covers on the
president looked like it would be
helpful to have to have a way to pick up
the front of me was the simple stick and
so I think you can simply by putting put
it another block in the back so you have
another lever point so they can't push
the stick in here and effectively think
of them like that
slide it over the bridge yeah
it's ready
as far back
one of our designs actually after this
experiment was sort of like a hole
insert where you could put in the hole
would but it was mostly put like more
yeah and then on the flip side trying to
minimize how much metal is used yeah
it's also important because it's
expensive so in the design that Jessica
just referenced you take your sheet and
it would have any thinner than this and
then you cut it like here and there and
need a certain point there and just bend
those two
just together
yeah and but I also wonder like if the
bricks are decently sealed against the
grass if you could make your device is
significantly smaller to just cover the
whole and not the whole area ah yeah
yeah
so I can't forward to it but if you open
if you exit out a PowerPoint you might
be able to load it in quick time or
whatever
here too
yeah it's totally like you don't want to
be rocking the barrel but we don't we
don't like they they did a different
order than we do in the video so we
normally just put the lid on top but
then we drop it down before you put the
sand so you don't have sand falling off
when you're rocking it so you don't
think I that's why i said like they
should try it because you don't have to
put the lid on
first
sushil are the ceiling yeah he asked for
what the
and what happened here was that the
grass um there's a lot fluffier here
then you got out what like over there
it's kind of burnt up kind of dry kind
of just not that much dressed um and so
we know that like there won't be that
much like air holes through the grass
then we'll have to see all stand all the
way around excessively like that
and other questions our thoughts our
partners
maybe we didn't think it was really a
problem in our experimentation you
didn't like you
still have like strands of the biomass
come out through the channels I'm in
just like them right there in fact it
may even be easier because there's no
[ __ ] passing through again so it wasn't
it's probably either the same or easier
than the current on Emilio's clock it
was 14 seconds which is more or less
where took us with other
great thank you
so hello everyone we're a group of
Phoenix what were the other particle
Phoenix we will travel together we
sprinted to project I'm one
we're pretty awesome electricity to cool
so I'm one type Liz I'm said and our and
our mentors are Amelia and steep so you
start with and currently we're working
with the comparative in solana grande
that makes the soap they make solar
cells they make solar panels and follow
the user perform our and also 4s
individual cell phone chargers currently
this is these are the large solar panels
that they make their 60 watts the you
can see solar cell is like is compass
donate em all the solar cells that are
you sir are donated and they're about it
about five hundred cells per box well
they do you have to be bad though yeah
oh sorry there by but they're bad for a
lot for a lower price because they're ok
they're rejects from the factory here in
the US the problem is that they're
really fragile and a lot of them break
on the shipping there and so right now
they're also making um sorry so right
now they're also making solar cell phone
chargers but to make the solar cell
phone chargers they need to cut each
individual cell so they can get a really
high swinging at a high enough voltage
but still have a small enough solar
panel that it's transportable um yeah so
this is just there's a landscape of the
the place where we are we can see there
is no greater than at other houses but a
lot of people still have cell phones and
so some of them have to walk up to two
or three kilometers in charge your cell
phones and they pay 10 corridors which
is about 50 cents per charge so that is
where that is how we want to get help
the project there's an example of a
Chinese makes the point charges and then
they have used as you can see it it
charges and it comes with an extra
battery and it charges the extra battery
in that device but there's only fits one
relief it's nokia cell phones & 2 is
just imported so this is not
don't think it's really helping the I
use them with the job market in the area
I'm twenty dollars oh it also costs 20
hours so so our goal is to make so this
is why you guys were this way I want to
make a cell phone charger so we want to
make one that is can hopefully compete
with this not on using like initial
manufacturing cars by least Anna can
cause to their own manufacturing costs
can reduce their time currently that it
takes in 24 hours to make the small so
quick chargers and it can also so time
and it comes to be transportable and
charge their cell phones and charge all
the different types of that they have
okay so on s Kwon said basically the
solar cells output point 5 volts each
and this is your original cell the way
they do it right now is that they cut up
these cells into four parts across like
that and then connect them in series so
you can step up your voltage
unfortunately what ends up happening is
when you're cutting these cells as one
mentioned they're very fragile so you
end up wasting a lot of your cells and
that actually is the largest like they
spend the most amount of their money in
cutting the cells and then using the
silicon but we'll get into that later um
so we decided that it would be helpful
if they could just use the original
cells instead of cutting them and so we
thought that if they just connected
three of these cells in series you could
go up to 1.5 volts which is about like a
normal pencil cell and then we thought
we would just step up that voltage to 5
volts which is what a cell phone charger
uses to do that we bought so to the
circuitry that we're using
so essentially like a lot I mean we
couldn't actually make the step up we
tried but we failed so we decided to
just buy like off the shelf and so this
is how our breadboard lips essentially
this would be your input right here and
this would be 1.5 DC input and then you
have a 5 volt DC output coming in from
here and basically your solar cells
would be connected bit so you're so
solar cells are here this little thing
fits in to this depression right here
and then so your panels are connected in
series you have two wires connecting to
these terminals it steps up to 5 volts
and goes out to connect to this thing
this thing then goes into your Nokia /
whatever phone you have and then charge
your phone arm is the video make sure my
volumes on them
yes we kind of like me to be here
ok so we're switching on the light so so
tweet sold right here now we're going to
measure voltage that solar cells so 1
point 6 volts that's good
I'm going to measure the voltage hood
after we step up
can you guys hear that is all there is
it so that's good come on is gonna like
in the cell phone
okay and it says charge
eight which is the voltage across the
battery so it makes sense that would
explode in extreme point eight bullets
instead of five yeah so that's basically
like works like yeah I think that's
pretty much yeah and then we've also
been talking to the community I'm a firm
at what hoping we can talk to them on
the phone soon this week they haven't
really been in contact who's it's Holy
Week but we sent them this in Spanish
and some other instructions about kind
of what we've been working on so we can
hope to get their feedback we like this
is our kind of looks like model you saw
it have said kind of can put the stuff
into this indentation here so that when
it's not in use or when I'd seen on noon
it can be completely flat this also
protects all of the the circuitry from
the liquor brain and that kind of thing
um there could be notches added to the
side so that for instance you could make
it lower by in a lower Indies and it
could be like that and stay still and
it's also something they can really
simply make they also make other things
with wood in the same center so they
have all the materials it's pretty low
cost and you can add you know we have a
hole here for security you can see in
the picture so that if they want to kind
of like tie it up and lock it to
something while it's charging they can
do that it's pretty portable but it's
also like not so small this one can just
stick it in our pocket and run away with
it it's adjustable just easy for them to
make so we're hoping that they like it
they can easily change the looks like
design as well most of how we're trying
to help them is acts like because
they're pretty capable of coming up with
things like this themselves but this is
just kind of a suggestion
we've also been talking with some other
people who are working on the other
aspects of the solar panels like the
like trying to make the application of
the glass on top easier and things like
that so other people have that part
covered so we're focusing a lot on just
making it actually build a charge a cell
phone and what we're looking to do next
is right now it's on the breadboard and
it's definitely like if you handed this
to a customer and we're like don't break
it like something's going to come out
and then they won't know what to do with
it so we have to make it more kind of a
able to be actually given to somebody
and not break so more durable I guess we
need to be able to make it easy to
explain so that because we might not
have anybody down there sewing them
think they can still learn how to do it
they have a mechanic I mean an engineer
who's been trained and should know how
to put this together reasonably well and
he's definitely better at soldering and
we are so it should be doable yeah I
like to be clear like this is uh this is
just a model of this is actually going
to be a solar panel like this is not
wood in case people who are kind of
intrigued since this is at the solar
panel but since our project focuses on
like converting the voltage to a cell
phone charging voltage we decided to
just like go with this just to show you
guys how it's going to look when solar
panel is in fact installed yeah 30 [ __ ]
333 yeah
crit yep pretty much yeah so so we
estimate so like right now we bought
five of each if you buy like large scale
like sorry like wholesale I think this I
think this thing should cost about four
dollars like this entire cost us laying
six this is about six for us but I think
you should cost for and then so the
connectors are actually more expensive
but that's because so there are two ways
to do it either you buy the whole thing
cut it off with that is make any sense
right so I look when we looked it up
online you can buy like about 10 of them
for seven dollars but they're probably
cheaper ways to buy them maybe if we
contacted the company asked him about it
we're still deciding how to get them for
cheap but we can definitely I think this
should be about a dollar max like if you
just buy it so and then when you add in
there like the time they'll use like it
probably will take them about eight
hours no because they want to cut cells
so that'll you know add another four
dollars or something cuz they like
getting paid about fifty cents an hour I
think so it'll definitely be able to
compete with the current one no problem
yeah
I think
sorry I'm sorry yeah he has that
so um so basically the concept like the
reason we decided to put in the
depression underneath was that like if
it did rain it wouldn't be immediately
affected that being said like this isn't
going to protect it against if you like
leave it on the rain it's not going to
protect it so I guess the concept is
that you leave it out only when it's
bright but if it suddenly starts to rain
it'll give you a certain amount of
protection against it before you can you
know take it back in the solar cells
themselves to be clear or not going to
be just like oh yeah we had to sub panel
like they'll still do the process of
which would like it's to silicon glass
on top because that's necessary you
can't I mean the cells get damaged if
you don't encapsulate that right i mean
just to be clear just so we realize mean
explain like how the panel looks the way
the panel looks is that like you have
the three solar cells in series which
are then encapsulated in Silicon you
have an aluminum frame yeah so you have
like an aluminum frame you have these
cells in series of and they're
encapsulated by silicon you then
pressure you put pressure on the glass
frame on top of it and leave it to like
set and then you have like a plastic
sheet underneath so this is basically a
waterproof and this is what we're
talking about will be here because these
are the kinds of panels if they stick on
their roofs and right of use for power
except like in our case you'd have only
three cells as opposed to yeah so it's a
lot less time a lot of the problems with
the big ones is when you encapsulate it
you have to push it down and make sure
that there's no air bubbles and it's
really hard in a big panel to make sure
there's no bubbles but of the smaller
ones it's mostly the cutting that they
said there they really need to get rid
of so that's what our goal was yeah I
mean the goal basically like was said is
still need cutting the cells because
that's a pain it's a pain and they break
they said like you know if they have
five cells or breaks or that
you're like it and so they won't break
these kids are just full styles right
but have you tried in lab pointing that
halogen light at the solar cell and
actually fully charging the phone I
think it's in the chart get me the
efficiency on that is so horrifying as
to be I mean it's like yeah point 0 1
percent I mean it's like 10am is 15
hands at 120 volts to get like a
kilowatt in the home which is crazy but
you should try it yeah we actually got
like the video we showed you was
yesterday so we're probably going to try
to the weekend yeah you should just set
it I mean find a phone that'll actually
give you like some kind of decent lead
out of how charged it is right yeah and
run it for you know half an hour and see
how see how much the charging influence
over a half an hour give or take out the
battery measure holding on the cell at a
couple different times or something we
did a rough calculation based on it
should have about 100 milliamp current
and look how long I should take and
it'll be longer than the Toronto when
the time was about five hours and this
hopefully will be like seven or eight
hours but we have not tested this so
that could be a big problem we have to
figure that out you may just find that
you need to have the storage there's not
enough if there's not enough current
coming out of that thing to charge in
real time you may have to add in that
typical
and we also been testing the voltage
necessarily actually get enough voltage
to put to thank so we can get enough
voltage that it can be stepped up to 5
volts and we're now going that is 1.2
volts is the minimum according to a
circuit we should be it we should be
able to step up to 5 volts using on
incoming seven books so we're going to
but it also shouldn't be much of a
problem because in the groundwork stunts
like it is about their half like it
would have to be like sunset for to be
that low it tastes charging a solar so
yeah but I mean yeah so we're definitely
going to try that though just trying to
charge the cell phone part of our
initial plan was actually to have a
separate energy some storage device like
in our system but we decided that that
would like increase costs and so we
thought that if you could do it without
done yeah so but yeah that's always a
possibility though yeah feedback from
our row or others a group of phoenix yet
we really need to talk to them like they
not very good at any bad to us okay so i
would encourage you to use the phone
next week yeah we want to target in this
moment then we have a lot of questions
at a conversation will be really helpful
yeah
how Nokia phones we only actually saw
two kinds of cell phones we saw the
okiya to CTE phone as a TV phone can be
charged in simple ways it's a same
voltage input oh yeah it's a different
connector we could also do this with a
USB charger but the nokia phone doesn't
can't be charged via USB so we just use
that we're waiting lindsay the women
taste like liaison that the other group
was talking about said that she has like
a spreadsheet with what kind of cell
phones everyone has but we're trying to
get that from her right but we asked a
lot of people at those are the only two
sofa with that right so I mean right now
we considered the two connectors we have
this one charge to knock in and this
one's a USB charger so
any more questions
I give you pink
as we speak we're actually going to pass
around the little ziploc bags of the
experiments we did with the rice and the
NGO that we worked with was called acid
pro star and we are actually part of the
class that went to El Salvador and
Nicaragua we worked in a community
called la Magdalena in El Salvador and
the NGO is currently introducing rice
cultivation in the community both to be
used as a source of income and also as
nutrition and in order for the rice to
be ready for consumption it needs to be
processed in the process involves
threshing and D husking and current
methods of D husking are very time and
money intensive they usually involve a
two to three-hour bus ride to a mill
where the rice can be processed and it
costs about three to four dollars we
found out which is about a daily salary
so our design challenge is to develop a
method that's for more local faster and
cheaper way of D husking rice the two
most important project specifications
that we focused on were the efficiency
which refers to the amount of rice
that's successfully d husk and also how
gentle the processes mean
we wanted to minimize the amount of rice
that's broken or cut in half and some of
the other specifications we looked at
where safety affordability of course
durability and also aesthetics we
approach the problem by brainstorming we
researched some existing technologies
that people use in regions that rice is
grown some of them are more simple some
of them involve heavy machinery what we
concluded though is that all of these
technologies use friction in order to
get the husk from the rice and it's a
matter of adjusting the amount of
friction we have in order to get the
husk off but not break the rice grain
and some of the ideas we ran through
were a pepper grinder where we have
cylinders rotating together rubbing
together plates that can be made from
different materials mortar and pestle
idea which is used but it's a lot more
energy intensive and not as efficient
and also the Mulino which is a corn mill
that's currently used in el salvador to
grain corn and that's basically two
circular plates that rub together and
that's what we actually have over there
so Amy azmuth actually had visited this
community before we had and she had
looked at this Molina and inserted a
black inner tube in between the two
metal parts so we use that kind of as
our standard when we were looking at how
we could go about improving this process
so we use as PHR with these attributes
to kind of figure out which would be the
most feasible to do this semester and
which one would be the most efficient
for the community to use overall in the
end we chose to modify the existing
Molino by inserting a different material
in between the plates right now we have
the two leather inserts in there if so
we kind of just add like a circular
insert in between them the advantages of
using the Molina is that our community
partner a suppressor is actually
distributing the molinos to the
community to use for corn to make
cornmeal to grind yucca too and like so
it's very multifunctional for them and
although the cost is twenty dollars as a
processor is funding this distribution
to the communities and as it is now
either one family will use it or a whole
community will use it so it's available
to a lot of people it's pretty durable
the metal is pretty rigid and it's not
labor-intensive it's just a hand crank
that you use a few of the challenges of
them we know though is that when you
just do it without any insert it cracks
or breaks the rice so people don't
really necessarily want broken rice
and it were as a material down if you
put something in there we kind of need a
durable material that will withstand
this turning um so we decided about five
different materials that we wanted to
test and we looked at leather rubber
metal wood and fabric and based on those
who looked at the cost residue
durability and availability of those we
brought back leather and rubber from El
Salvador so we actually could use stuff
that was built available in those
communities and Missy will talk to you
about what we found so we did a quite a
few experiments where the main variables
that we're really testing on what type
of material that we wanted to use and
then also how many turns of the Molina
that we were going to do so first to
just highlight the main steps of the
experiments that we did first we enter
the material and then in order to be
able to accurately measure how much
space they are actually existed in
between the sides of the Mulino and the
insert we tightened it as far as we
could once we inserted the material and
then we measured it from the number of
turns out so how much we actually
loosened it from the most type position
and then we use the same amount of rice
for each experiment 50 grams and we ran
it through and once had gone through the
Mulino we sifted it through to get rid
of the really crushed pieces and then we
winnowed it so essentially just tossing
the rice up so the error will catch it
and blow the husks the way so you can
get rid of the husks and then we
separated the rice into four main
components
being the rest that was still has the
rights that was hold the rice that was
crush or broken and then also if there
are any husks left as well and then we
noted and you'll see the bags themselves
are labeled as they're going passing
around how many turns that it took and
then the number the weight of the still
hospitalized the weight of the strikes
and if it was in pieces and such so this
is a hole like this picture is the
picture of the rice that has is still
has a whole grain of Jesus Christ a
broken grain and then some of the
particles that we use to sift through to
get rid of and so one of the experiments
we use with the honeycomb rubber is what
we called it let's pictures kind of
self-explanatory what we called that but
so we did a couple experiments with this
and you can see in the pictures that we
have whether the it's kind of hard to
see from these pictures but once we've
separated it through what how much of
the rice is still has how much of the
rice it has been dejes based on the
number of turns what we noted about the
rubber though is that we work very sure
how hazardous the residue that might end
up on the rice would be because it's not
an organic material we also noted that
this rubber cost about six dollars per
square foot so it's not too expensive
another we decided to flip that rubber
around and decided to test with the
different textures and the same thing
happens with this rubber against not
organic so we did a quick little data
sheet based on the number of turns and
the mass we started with and then the
masa was broken and just to get an idea
then we continued on with leather which
was the kind since its organic and a
little bit cheaper than the rubber made
us feel a little bit better as the one
kind of preferred and it's very readily
tested but we were trying to decide how
many layers of the leather we should put
so
right so as we did the experiments with
the leather sometimes we processed it
through twice sometimes we did different
number of turns with different layers
and you can see most of them are
relatively the same somewhere a little
bit better but ultimately we decided
well we decided that the material wasn't
the biggest part but we still have
decided to test with a duct tape which
we found unfortunately war why
relatively quickly and then we tried for
the heck of it a flat sheet metal
surface and essentially that was a
disaster so I'll hand it over to Benjy
so the so one of the reasons that we
decided to go against the flat metal is
because the rice wasn't actually fed
into the Mojito of the way that the
plate the way that the back plate is
design and shape the if these in the
rice and so we decided to focus on the
one side of on the backside of the
bonito and just adding the material
there um so as you can see like we have
a lot of the tests and we did a lot of
tests but actually there was no
conclusive like awesome material that
was way better at hunting the rice in
the
and so basically we said okay well the
the we noticed that the most important
variable for deciding that was the
number turns away from you know from
tightening it and so we said well you
know we still have to decide on the
material so we wanted to optimize how
much how much rice is broken and also
just think about the robustness and the
available to living the material and so
we decided on choosing leather because
of the availability and because them
because it is organic it's much safer
and so go we did a couple more
exploratory tests with the leather and
trying to decide how soft we wanted to
make the leather effectively like how it
interacts with the rights and so we
tried with two pieces of leather glued
together than three pieces together and
unsurprisingly we actually thought they
were very similar as well of so you know
so we decided on going with two pieces
of leather rather than the dream because
it's just less material
and so going forward we're going to be
optimizing that sort of two layer
process or you know how we're going to
be gluing those together you know what
type of glue or if we're going to stone
together because it might not be
available and so we'll be looking at
those sort of details of of that leather
material but also we wanted to look at
the process of how it's being how it's
being put through the mill so not only
changing the material but also thinking
well if we change the number of turns to
you know say three times more than usual
and then going through it twice you know
does that change the results at all I
cute more gentle with with the rice at
you process through it twice while has
been more of the material so we'll be
looking at that earth we can do anything
to the rights of prior to actually
running through the
4d husky again so that's about it if you
guys have any questions we can also show
how this is working so hard
and then
so
oh yeah maybe we can do a little more
such easier oh yeah it takes a little
bit of the first two turns in the last
night oh yeah it takes a while to start
they just need some amount of rice to be
sued were you did that's just from a
little bit though already there's a lot
of broken pieces so i could with this
setup we thought of that like four five
six turns like having the race and i
actually be host oh it's an injustice
we'd rather have Rachel do you not do
how excessively long pieces
I'm not sure if you guys also saw the
bag I was just a broken so basically it
still has it still have to know that I
made it this leather tanning I mean that
leather could be the most toxic than you
have yeah conceivably I mean like one of
the things that is used in leather
tanning is like chromium sulphate as the
tanning agent so you like it's just
worth finding out I mean another option
is canon where she comes from poachers
guess it's not a lot of options but yeah
it's worth finding out
because it would be sad to poison
everybody sorry that by disasters well
they can do my dear dr. Fairall bit okay
also we've been we've been waiting for
them to respond to
the questions but some of the questions
that we've been trying to get answers to
or how many how many people may meet the
many people can use it it would be a
family or whole community and how much
rights do they consume how much I can
make grow and I think that's gonna it's
going to be important for us to know in
terms of the material how durable the
material is is that this each family of
a piece of this leather or is it
permanently attached to the malayan so
there's a lot of questions like this
though I just wouldn't take for granted
what isn't is it Thompson based on like
as a rubber could be fine for all we
know and the leather poisonous and again
if what comes off as stuff that you can
wash off and I stop here well the
problems in their tube was that I was
leaving like a black president right
right yeah if it's like marking with a
crayon in each one yeah but if there's
like you know a little bit of rubber
dust that comes off but it's not hearing
anything wash it off and I lighter
yellow wherever yeah yeah so just worth
expert you know actually finding out
what the what chemicals are actually
present because in my titis you could
eat a loaf of that rubber and you can
find Frankie she won the weather for a
little bit it says she's hard to control
that you know that you like the shops
will be
yeah yeah yes well i think i think it's
worth figuring out like worst case
scenario this leather is tanned with
bring whatever chemicals changes mention
is that something that's going to get
absorbed into the rice or something
that's going to be washed off during
processing if it's going to get absorbed
maybe we need to knock this leather out
as a contender to find something similar
because it seemed like different
materials also you can work basically
the same and so you know who would have
an old t-shirt work just as well or
something at around I'm a fabric work
yeah so that's the reason we did the
duct tape was like not as an actual sort
of design but just to see how long it
lasts because it is like wear resistant
but it does wet and like woody or the
trike with this foam material and that I
think you can see that now with 50 grams
look at the 50 with even running like
this much of 50 grams with the duct tape
you could tell Warren and like actually
do tests with between some denim and
leather like up for motorcycles and like
they simulate someone falling down and
like the weather lasts for 90 feet of
dragging while denim last 45 so and
denim is like very durable right like
inside tangentially about the inside of
these and
oh yeah and so trying to grand right
sandy yeah gonna wreck late or even both
sides are bridge that's a reason why
that it's made out of oh yeah so that's
how you're thinking and doing flat metal
so that that was more durable but you
know like I mentioned we need the we
need to design the metal piece that goes
on the side to be make the inner hole
big enough so that the rice to come out
yeah so you so it needs the like this in
a jutting or any other dimension like it
can't actually just be a flat surface no
matter how big the hole is because the
rice isn't allowed to like feed into it
these were just like where the material
now it's on both sides have you found I
didn't go look I was too busy looking up
how you tan leather while you were
talking about this oh but there are all
over YouTube there are videos of like
how manufacturing processes happen
usually they put up by the people who
built the equipment of any be curious
how they actually like home
actually it's us yes they do it they do
with like rollers basically like rubber
rollers a lot of times which is it's a
totally different geometry though yeah
but like you said it's like the friction
yeah I just wonder if there's pieces of
that you can steal yes you know like
like if that's too coarse but a flat
plate with a single slot cut in it would
get you you know you know like if you
had if you had groups cut in it that
happened to be about the right size for
a grain of rice or something no just one
there are tricks just not being too far
out but what about like a tumbling
across
grinding process yeah the submarine
there's a both team also joining us
but ring is actually very soft and it
doesn't end up getting damaged by the
tumblers where the plus the husks are
actually pretty soft and the rice is
hard so if there were tumblers that like
just looking at it the rice would
probably get more crushed whereas of us
probably as much that we found that the
soft materials really like give it
allowed the hops to come off reaction
but not damage your mice as much
that's something that we actually that
we wanted to ask the community I can't
get too mushy for the couch well part of
the reason we they want to use like this
as a tool in their community as I want
to sell rice too so I assume we haven't
been the contact
back to us that we would assume that
they want assembled
one question adding them
you may ask is what their expectations
are for growing rice if they already
from the mill they get when rumors
already and they just graduate
so I look at on the phone yeah actually
kamicheetah if you went whatever
material you end up with when there's
leather or something else figuring out
just how long it does last so how many
grams you can process before you to
replace it and then getting like a both
for your users that they know it we
should be reprocessed replacing it this
elephant and also so you can get a cost
estimate for like we're going to year
you know are this many tons of rice
we're going to need this much leather or
whatever it is be useful
did you bring the rice back from Osama
no is it from like a partner by
wordpress com it is from so far but I
mean from comparison they
nobody's going to let you bring a sack
that one must erase if you did you did
hit a balled-up socks hey thanks you
guys
you